What is in the box?
The box is big and brown.
The big brown box goes in the mail.
The box gets stamped.
The big brown box goes in the car.
The box gets smashed.
The big brown box goes on the boat.
The box gets wet.
The big brown box goes on the train.
The box gets placed.
The big brown box goes on the plane.
The box gets torn.
The big brown box goes in the truck.
The box gets tossed.
The big brown box goes in the van.
The box gets dropped.
The man takes the big brown box to the door.
The man knocks on the door.
A girl opens the door.
"Special Delivery.",...
...says the man.
Where is Brian? Do you see him?
He is going to school. He goes in the car.
Where is Mrs. Baker? Do you see her?
She is going to New York. She goes on the plane.
Where is my dog, Max? Do you see him?
He is going to the vet. He goes in the van.